je n'ai jamais mendié j'ai toujours
travaillé
je ne suis même pas capable de avoir un
toit pour mon fils alors qu'il est né en
France tu aurais cru que j'en arriverai
là jamais je n'ai plus mais là j'ai
touché le fond
[Musique]
si on craque c'est fini on est à terme
on peut plus rien faire dans la vie
en positive demain c'est un autre jour
elle a tout dit
il s'est passé quoi
salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien aujourd'hui je voulais vous
raconter l'histoire de Naomi et de Henri
c'est ici un sur le parvis de l'Hôtel de
Ville de Paris en plein centre de la
capitale que j'ai rencontré la première
fois Naomi c'est une mère célibataire
qui est à la rue depuis seulement
quelques jours avec son fils de 15 ans
en ri normalement dans leur situation
ils auraient dû appeler le numéro
d'hébergement d'urgence le 115 pour être
mise à l'abri mais la réalité c'est que
tous ces services sont complètement
saturés aujourd'hui du coup ce sont les
associations qui prennent le relais et
tous les soirs ici à 18h il y a des
membres de la solution Utopia 56 qui
accueille des dizaines et des dizaines
de familles sans abri donc là il fait
presque 0° et il y a des bébés de
parfois quelques semaines qui vont
attendre des heures dehors dans le froid
pour espérer d'avoir une place pour la
nuit venez vous discutez pas ne vous
discutez pas ça va aller ok c'est pas la
peine de discuter tirer l'attention on a
assez des problèmes comme ça donc
rajouter des problèmes c'est pas bon
c'est l'enfant à qui ah c'est la fille à
la dame qui est passée tout à l'heure ta
maman est passée là hein elle est
quelque part ici je sais pas où elle est
elle est là tu veux passer
alors vous étiez là hier ok vous êtes
combien du coup vous et le bébé vous
êtes deux vous pouvez le petit
salut
mais vous inquiétez pas c'est pas grave
on va trouver une solution il est trop
mignon votre fils ah vous êtes en
demande avec votre petite c'est que la
fille qui est en demande
et toi tu préfères quoi comme
hébergement n'importe quoi juste pour
dormir ce serait bien n'importe quoi
en France depuis plus de 20 ans son fils
et même né ici donc ils ont leurs
papiers ils sont parfaitement en règle
si aujourd'hui ils sont dans cette
situation là c'est simplement qu'en tant
que mère célibataire aujourd'hui Naomi
elle n'arrive pas du tout à payer un
hébergement à Paris il n'y a pas des
fois où tu craques ou tu te dis que tu
vas pas y arriver non jamais ça jamais
ça vient un truc que j'ai jamais baissé
les bras c'est ça j'ai besoin les bras
toujours j'ai positif voilà j'ai jamais
craqué parce que si on craque c'est fini
on est atteint un peu plus rien faire
dans la vie il faut toujours être plus
fort fort fort jusqu'à même si il y a
des moments que c'est pas bon ben on
positif demain c'est un autre jour il y
a meilleur
bonsoir est-ce que votre nom de famille
ça ça fait depuis excusez-moi depuis le
1er janvier qu'on est là ça m'inquiète
beaucoup je comprends je vais rechercher
un tout petit truc
[Musique]
j'ai froid je peux mettre la capuche ou
pas oui
c'est bon on peut partir ok merci ok
déplaçons laissons la place pour les
autres viens ok merci beaucoup OK
s'il vous plaît
merci
et pourquoi tu m'as pas pris la salade
à la
2 minutes
et ça suffit pour un grand garçon de 15
ans comme toi
oui même si je préférerais plus c'est
déjà bien
c'est ça
on apprend à se contenter déjà du peu
connard
vous êtes au niveau de l'hôtel de ville
oui du coup on a une place pour vous ce
soir est-ce que vous me voyez là si
j'avais la main du coup on a une place
pour toi ce soir aux Acacias tu vois où
c'est l'espace où on a des tentes ça
vous va si on part maintenant aux
Acacias et comme ça vous mangez là-bas
tranquillement là en tout du coup ça
fait 16 17 personnes
tous les enfants que vous voyez ici ils
passeraient la nuit dehors je ne veux
plus
voir
des faux qu'un enfant ne doit dormir à
la rue cet hiver et nous travaillerons
en permanence pour faire que cette
situation ne soit pas acceptable et
selon l'Unicef il y aurait près de 42000
enfants son domicile fixe en France
aujourd'hui le nombre d'enfants à la rue
a doublé en un an et malgré les discours
officiel il n'y a toujours pas assez de
place d'hébergement d'urgence
[Musique]
donc là on est dans notre tiers-lieu
qu'on a rebaptisé les acacias qui a été
aménagé voilà avec des matelas et des
tentes ce qui nous permet actuellement
de pouvoir héberger
70 personnes donc là on a un espace ici
sanitaire et la cuisine qui est équipée
au fur et à mesure par on va dire des
Dombes bénévoles le frigo le micro-ondes
les thermos
tu as le voici maintenant
dormir avec moi
[Musique]
que je peux dormir autre chose sans cela
vous voyez
[Musique]
il a fait deux trois jours une semaine
même j'étais au dehors avec votre fille
de 4 ans
voilà madame en état de grossesse avancé
la Guinée
là où l'excision est obligatoire j'ai vu
mes sœurs mourir à cause de l'excision
avec ma fille je préfère quitter le pays
c'est tout ce que je fais je fais à
cause de de ma famille voilà c'est ce
qui m'a poussé de d'accepter tout va
dormir au dehors sur le froid avec la
famille ça me dérange pas parce que si
je peux protège ma fille
ça n'a pas de prix
[Musique]
vous aimeriez quoi vous comme
hébergement c'est quoi votre rêve
c'est d'avoir une maison
moi aussi
un parc qui est trop bien à côté de ma
maison
[Musique]
une école pourquoi tu aimes bien l'école
c'est pour les enfants très durs pour
nous d'accord j'ai aussi malade les
enfants très très malade parce que c'est
froid ça fait combien de temps que vous
avez pas d'hébergement du mois de moi
et vous venez de quel pays je vais venir
Kazakhstan
[Musique]
il y a 20 ans que j'ai vécu en France je
ne connaissais pas ce que c'était mais
aujourd'hui je suis concernée demain à
notre peut être concerné on dit jamais
on n'est jamais à l'abri on sait pas ce
que l'avenir nous réserve toujours
dans ma vie jamais je n'ai plus en
arriver là mais là j'ai touché le fond
voilà j'ai plus rien j'ai que ce que je
porte sur moi
[Rires]
mais je suis trop grande
la YouTube pousse comme si j'étais une
bouteille d'eau comme ça
tu prends plus de place que moi et
comment vous faites pour garder cette
joie de vivre cette énergie c'est
naturel je dirais parce que hier dans la
vie quand on vit et qu'on a pas la joie
de vivre ça ne sert à rien de vivre vous
voyez donc ma joie c'est c'est bien moi
et ça il y a rien et ni personne pourra
me l'enlever je suis accroché à cela
donc on va fermer on
je retourne aux Acacias pour retrouver
Naomi et Henri en fait toutes les
familles doivent libérer le lieu à 8h
ils peuvent revenir que le soir parce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que la majorité
des enfants évidente ici sont scolarisés
malheureusement c'est pas le cas d'un
Henri
[Musique]
vous arrivez à vous y habituer à ce
quotidien
on ne peut pas s'habituer on n'a pas le
choix c'est la seule solution et surtout
ce qui me dérange le plus c'est comme
mon fils il va pas à l'école alors que
ce matin il devrait pas là pour l'école
donc voilà
pourquoi c'est compliqué quand on est
dans votre situation de s'inscrire dans
la vie c'est inscrit parce qu'il faut
une domiciliation il faut avoir une
adresse fixe et nous n'avons pas mais
moi je peux pas travailler même si j'ai
un travail actuellement comment je vais
laisser je peux pas voir le cœur
tranquille même si il a 15 ans je peux
pas c'est mineur avant tout on le laisse
pas tout seul donc
voilà ça vous inquiète pour l'avenir de
votre fils beaucoup du mien et de lui
aussi beaucoup je préfère bien avoir une
positive attitude parce que dire c'est
pas bien c'est pas bien alors qu'il y a
pire que nous franchement ici on arrive
à dormir on a retrouvé quelque chose
pour passer la nuit au chaud
franchement autant en profiter
on a même pas eu l'occasion de se
brosser les dents vous voyez parce que
les toilettes n'étaient pas propres donc
il fait froid ici
à l'école les vacances sont finies ça
fait déjà combien de jours que tu as
manqué là-bas
chercher sur Internet les informations
il y a quoi tu penses
tu as bien dormi
[Musique]
toute la nuit ça n'allait pas
ça va
est-ce que vous pouvez me dire qu'est-ce
que vous allez comme parcours
professionnel parcours professionnel
j'ai arrêté les études au niveau des 3e
donc voilà j'ai fait la couture le
maquillage le sport voilà et ici en
France j'étais serveuse en salle de
trouver un travail pour moi oui à Paris
pour moi je n'ai jamais je n'ai aucun
problème c'est le problème c'est le
logement ou stabilité
[Musique]
voilà donc c'est après à gauche on va au
point du jour passer la journée là où on
peut prendre notre douche c'est laver
s'échanger faire notre lessive prendre
un déjeuner en attendant le soir encore
bonjour
[Musique]
nous allons manifester pour avoir un
logement en espérant que la mairie ne
réponde
et tu crois j'espère
c'est un espoir on essaye
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde
monsieur s'il vous plaît sur le Barbie
allez s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est où ta mère à l'intérieur du
cercle un cerclé par la police il s'est
passé quoi
vous criez comme si vous avez gagné au
loto il y a rien
[Applaudissements]
et c'est presque 0 degré et ces familles
avec des enfants en bas âge elles vont
rester encerclées par la police jusqu'à
1h du matin finalement la mairie va
accéder à leur demande et vont les
envoyer au milieu de la nuit dans la
gymnase au sud de Paris au Naomi et
Henry sont toujours hébergés au moment
où je termine ce montage
[Musique]
d'un détortoir en attendant mieux nous
avons vu des personnes donc on attend
allez-y voilà c'est la fin de ce
reportage j'espère que vous avez appris
des choses si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas
à la commenter à liker à la partager à
vous abonner à notre chaîne YouTube
d'ailleurs c'est des coulisses de mon
travail vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à
vous rendre sur la chaîne Youtube
Camille reporter qui est ma chaîne
youtube et je vous dis à très bientôt
pour une nouvelle vidéo